hey everybody is Jessie today we're
going to use jQuery with react which
some of you might be shocked at that if
you read a lot of articles and tutorials
usually they tell you not to use jQuery
with react and then they're usually
right but sometimes you you already are
using it or you have to use it for some
reason in this case I'm using the
materialized framework which needs
jQuery for some of the things that it
does also if if you haven't seen some of
the earlier videos when I started this
project the idea was that first we had a
really really tight timeline so the
first thing we were going to do was make
a just a static site and have that ready
to launch if we couldn't actually link
up the WordPress CMS and with react like
we're doing now
well the the launch day got pushed back
to this Thursday and that gave us enough
time to actually do it the way that I
wanted it to be from the beginning but
in trying to complete that static site
as fast as I possibly could I use some
jQuery so now I need to make that jQuery
work with react so I've had some success
so far and making things work and I'll
show you what I've done and then we're
going to try to make this this
navigation piece let me show you so this
red navigation bar was sticky if you
remember when we had the static site it
was sticky when we converted this to
react site it started throwing errors in
the console
so I disabled the stickiness of it just
so that I could get rid of the airs
temporarily until I had time to fix it
so now it's time to fix it and let me
make this bigger so we can all see oh if
you watched yesterday and saw that I I
went through everything and then
couldn't get it to work the whole
problem was I forgot to save the file so
super embarrassing
I had hard-coded that hello world page
in so that I was searching for the data
from the hello world post and then when
I switched over to use the variable that
was getting passed in I never saved it
so it totally works now you can go on
the the demo site there's a link and if
you go into the to the news portion of
it you can click on the different news
articles it will take you to the right
page so everything we did yesterday
worked I I just didn't save it that's
how it didn't work
hey everybody I got a lot of people
saying hi in the latch at I'll answer
one question before you start it what's
the best way to get started with react
probably find it's called create react
app and that's what is called so
assuming that you know how NPM works and
you can you know pull down packages like
that then find create react app and you
can download that start it up everything
will be kind of pre-made for you so you
have less options to customize but it's
really helpful to get you started on
that so I would definitely check that
out and if your just read read through
some of the tutorials on reacts site
they're actually pretty good and what
some some videos hopefully after I
launch the site will have time to do
some
short videos highlighting some nice
resources and give us some little
tutorials and that's one of the topics
that I'm going to touch on okay so let's
get to this so this big section of code
here that I've commented out is what
controls the sticky nav so let's get rid
of these comments and see what happens I
think that's it now I need this
okay oops okay so I think there we go
I think that's everything that I
commented up is now back in alright so
let me make sure I save that this time
and we're gonna let me bring this keep
this over here let me refresh make sure
with changes are in there okay we can
see nothing's happening okay so our
sticky NAB that was working when we had
in-page snap is not defined all right so
I'm getting an error I'll bring this
over and show you so it's giving us this
error it was working when the other
static site is not working now it's
saying that in page nav is not defined
and ass on line one for T so let's go
back is this something in vision
where is that coming from
yes
seems like
maybe I didn't need that so I'm
obviously not defining that anywhere
maybe I pulled that over from my
previous project and didn't really need
it let's just try again all right and
[Music]
refresh oh nice okay so you are getting
this working here but what I keep having
happen to me is that sometimes these
will work and sometimes they won't work
I'm not exactly sure why but when I
actually put this on a server
pretty much everything I'm trying to do
a jQuery has not been working I'm not
exactly sure why so here's what I did to
get around that so let me show you oh
actually I'll put this on the on the
server in a second and again I'll show
you guys how I do that or at least how
I'm doing it right now so here's what I
did okay so normally you would just put
everything in your document ready
function for jQuery so and that that
would run for whatever reason it doesn't
always run it's not always finding
things when they're getting loaded so if
I want to be able to actually call these
like let's say from my component I need
to make them available globally so this
is kind of looks like a little
workaround there's probably a better way
to do this I've looked up before but
never
exactly figured out ways to just use
jQuery right within a react component so
like import it in and use it there and I
haven't gotten it to work not that it's
not doable I just couldn't couldn't get
it to work and since I'm on such a tight
timeline for this project I didn't want
to attempt to get that to work so
instead I knew this would work I had
some things let's do this background
scroll so let me show you we had this on
the home page we have this effect and so
I have this effect of scrolling it's a
meeting let me refresh it for a second
it should it shouldn't cut that off
unless I not a not a great start
everything I'm trying to do is either
working when I expected it not to work
or not working when I expected it to
work so I'm just going to restart the
the dev server here because it was it
just kept loading so that's like it's
pretty fast it'll start in just a few
seconds all right it's ready okay so the
effect that I had which for some reason
is is cutting off here when it it was
not cutting off previously but the
effect that I have basically is this is
like kind of like a parallax effect in
the background and then it stops and
then it starts flowing normally with the
page okay so that's that's what we're
trying to do I thought that I had fixed
this part so it was cutting this image
off but I guess I haven't so here's what
I did I'm just going to run through this
quickly is that how I did it's not
important but
just me about how we get it to work as
within our react component is more
important so basically just using some
jQuery right because for two reasons one
we already have to look Jake here on
this page for materialized and to jQuery
can save a lot of time and I don't have
a lot of time right now so all I'm doing
is I'm tracking the scroll as as the
user Scrolls down and once they get to a
certain point in the page I'm changing
the background position Y and I'm
changing it by a certain amount let's
let me see what this variable is so
basically I'm changing in in correlation
to the scroll so like every time you
scroll one pixel the position changes by
one pixel so that's why once you get
down to here and start scrolling up it
actually is changing the position of
this by one pixel
every time I scroll one pixel okay so
that's how I get the effect I tried just
kind of changing it from like background
attachment fixed to a different like
just to initial or something that I had
like a big jerk so at some point it
would just change position this very
abruptly and it didn't look nice the
other thing I added to try to help get
rid of this you know getting cut off
here was I did add a check to see what
the width was of the window so depending
on the width it adjusts the position so
I just have I just kind of set this in
line with a little ternary operator here
so it's like if the window is larger
than 1540 pixels they were going to
adjust it either up or down so you have
a negative 12
adjustments are down or positive 12% up
so for whatever reason I wasn't it's not
exactly working right now so all right
there yeah I think maybe my since I have
the screen in like a weird kind of
square which is not really a normal
screen size nowadays that's what was
giving me okay so that's kind of how
it's supposed to look you should be able
to see that part all right so enough
about the how I did that the problem was
when I first did this and I just had
this whole thing inside my document
ready function it wasn't working and the
same thing with with this one you see a
kind of a similar thing happened with
this one a scroll function which I just
wanted to have some buttons to scroll
horizontally on a place where I have a
responsive table okay so it worked when
I tested it but when I put it on the
server this would not work it was not it
was not recognizing this this div at all
so nothing was working on it so how I
solved it was I pulled this function out
out of the document dot ready so I
pulled all this code out I put it in a
function I give it this name now when I
go to was my index page of it open so
this exists on the index page so now I
actually call I can call this from
inside my component so I have this
component did mount and I call this
function inside of there so the function
actually did it needed to be called
and I tag could test that out in the you
know the console where if I would call
the function it would run but if
just relied on that document already
function it wouldn't it wouldn't work
you wouldn't run so that's one way it
kind of quick an easy way to get your
components working now there could be
some issues like let's say you have some
components that aren't may not be loaded
all right when this component did mount
fires then you might want to wrap this
and in a function that would wait until
the site loaded entirely and that would
work if it was farther down on the page
and the odds of somebody scrolling there
before that actually worked we're really
slim so for in this case I don't need to
do that it works and let me show you
I'll pull in the actually have it here
okay so this is the version of the site
the that's on our test URL so this is
actually running on the server the
differences
we're running next j/s which is our J's
framework we're running it in production
mode instead of dev mode and there are
some differences one difference that I
have found that's it's a little bit
frustrating if you're not aware of it at
first is when the hot reload happens
sometimes things just don't work so some
of your JavaScript stuff or your Styles
just occasionally you'll have a weird
glitch where things won't work so if
that happens don't freak out just
refresh the page and it usually works
after that you won't ever have that
problem in production because you're not
using the hot module reloading obviously
in production so let's go to the home
page and we'll see this should work
alright so that works
one other thing to watch out for that
I've had happen to me when I'm using
this is right now all of this is being
server-side rendering and served up so
you can watch watch this little you know
loading indicator here when I click
team right it's actually reloaded that's
it that's an entire page refresh but
normally you know if you're working with
react a lot of times you don't want that
page reload you want it to just you
click it and everything gets pulled in
it's all handled client-side so you want
that client-side routing you get you
that immediate route right to the next
page and you don't even have to do a
page refresh so if you're going to do
that your document ready function is not
going to fire right because it already
has fired right it's not going to happen
again so you can't leave your JavaScript
in there and expect it to work
so I'm actually doing that and it works
for some things so let me show you back
here in our JavaScript so for instance
this this scroller function I'm using on
the events page let me find that just to
show you so if you see on the events
page I'm not calling anything from here
yeah but in the document dot ready
function at the bottom here I am
actually calling it this scroller right
I'm actually calling this as well just
uh I was frustrated trying to get it to
work so I was trying to run this
function everywhere I could think of to
get it to work so I'll probably verify
that this doesn't need to be in here and
then possibly take it out before this
actually goes live just to get rid of
some unnecessary code but I'm calling
that here inside the document dot ready
function and since right now we're doing
all our routing like more traditionally
where we have a page refresh this will
still work let's go to the events page
just to show you and we'll go down to
the bottom and here's the the scrolling
thing let me shrink the page so you can
actually get a scroll okay so this is
a responsive style table so I can scroll
like this or I can use these buttons to
scroll okay the reason I put this in is
since this scroll bar gets automatically
hidden I don't think it's hidden on all
browsers but at least Chrome on iOS
automatically hides this I wanted users
to know that they could scroll so I put
these buttons in and since I was going
to have these buttons and I figured
people are going to try to click those
so it needs to do something so we have
this girl so you can see if you're using
traditional routing you can still call
things from your document.ready function
and they will work but not if you're
using the client-side routing and let's
let's just enable that just to show what
happens what works and what doesn't work
so if you're not familiar with next j/s
check out their their dogs on get up I
think I have the link in the description
you will you'll see about I guess I'll
bring up the ducks since I have it here
no that's not it I said yeah okay I'll
make this a little bit bigger so we can
follow along okay so let's go to routing
all right so check this routing here so
we can enable client-side transitions
between routes if we just use the link
component we can also prefetch I'm not
getting able to prefetch now maybe at
some point if we have time probably not
before launch we can go over this
prefetching it is pretty cool we can
save some time with loading but right
now we just need to pull this in we need
to import link and then we need to wrap
our link we'll grab our
taking AB menu link and this mic here so
we're actually going to go to our
component for that stinky nav so let's
find that stinking EV and we'll import
link and this is something that's built
into next so if you're just using react
without using next you won't won't have
this alright so now let's make let's
make this events a link because I think
let's check the dogs just to be sure
okay we just need to change it okay
we're going to wrap it in the link and
we'll keep the ax so link and then we're
going to put in href I'm going to move
the HRF to this link tag and we can move
this inside the link and we can remove
this I'm not going to worry about the
title right now I think that should be
fine there and we're save it okay now
let's look here let me see I couldn't I
couldn't tell if this whoa
and get a lot of errors right now okay
okay did you see I don't the era's are
heard oh I'll show you the air is in a
second but knock you're trying to fit
now we're still getting a page refreshes
see why that didn't work
sorry if I'm losing you it's just is not
working right now what happened here
okay so we are importing this we're
using the link tag I guess we can pull
this off just since it was like that in
the in the docks
okay
all right so we're on the events page
verify this let me shrink this we can
verify that this still works okay so
that still works now we want to go to a
different page and flip back okay so
actually a routing just isn't working at
all right now
I'm thinking maybe just what the hell
want to check maybe this has to be on a
page
we can check the example here next is a
good job of having a little example
projects so we can just go in here and
check ok so they are running this on an
actual page let's try to run it on a
page and see if that makes a difference
or actually it looks like our server is
not working right now so let's restart
it I'm getting an error on my server
I've been it's been happening for like a
week now where sometimes it will just
hang I think I mentioned this at a video
last week so so far it's just annoying
and it hasn't slowed me down that much
all right so let's let's try this not
huh okay I don't know if you notice that
what's happening is it is refreshing
it's refreshing and not only that but
we're getting all these errors here and
these were the areas that I actually
expected to get for that sticky knife
it's saying cannot repro pre top of
undefined okay let's look what it's
trying to find is this the sticky knife
this original sticky nav and it can't
find it it can't so it obviously can't
get the position so
let's try let's try to do a refresh okay
so let's verify
okay well this now it now that you
started working let's see okay there we
go alright so here's what's happening so
we finally got it to work so I think the
the client-side routing is actually
working now for that I don't know why
it's still giving me a little a little
flash I'll have to check this up to be
sure Wow okay my dev tools just crashed
so it's getting so many errors from that
let's open that up again yeah I'm still
getting all these errors so let's leave
this page for a second so that we don't
get we don't keep getting all these
errors whoa
Wow what did I break if you guys notice
me do something
hey let me know because now I'm getting
so many errors and everything's not
working I have not had this happen
before
hmm that's weird all right let me let's
go check and make sure that we didn't
accidentally change something that we
shouldn't have so the only files that
we've really changed let me let me go
I'm just going to do the git status just
to see what we change the only thing we
changed was the component stinky nav
component and the app.js file okay so
let's check it out
so we brought this code back in and that
was fine we already we tested this and
this worked okay we have this bottom out
of class class original okay so it's
doing a lot of this stuff and let me
verify that we are actually calling this
the proper name okay we do a bottom now
all right awesome let's let's add in
just like we did for the southern
component or yet on the index page so on
our index page we added in something
like this I want to give this a try
since it works for that page let's give
this a try and see how this forward in
case you haven't heard me say this in
previous videos this video is just about
showing me going through my daily work
mistakes included so it's not exactly a
tutorial I will be doing some tutorial
videos when I get a chance and I'll put
those on by my own channel so as we go
through this this is not rehearsed this
is actually me having real problems and
trying to figure them out I saved this
for I did a lot of other stuff today but
I knew this was going to give me a lot
of trouble so I saved it so
this was at least somewhat on purpose to
have things break because I think it's
more interesting for the video so I
apologize if you expected more of a
tutorial and some of them will be more
tutorial like but sometimes everything
just goes wrong and we have to figure
out what's going on all right so let's
first what we need to do is pull this
out let's grab everything everything we
need here and we're going to pull that
out and we're going to put it in a
function we'll just put it up here
function should we call this this is
such thinking that right we'll just call
it sticking out and let's throw all that
in there and save it and now we'll go
back here and let's see if we can call
that we're going to save that and let's
go back to this you better refresh okay
so the sticking app works now let's try
it on this events page that was what
freaked everything out last time all
right it's working I'm also not getting
a millionaire's and my console like we
were before okay that's nice not bad let
me click a few more times just to see if
we can recreate all those errors that we
had we go back here
I think our gosh test servers hanging
again so well that's hanging
what we'll do is I'll show you how I am
putting this on the server right now
because I don't think I should showing
you that yet so let me bring this in
right now I'm just going to say I'm just
going to push this to get because what
we're going to use get to put this on
the server so all somebody else with
theme I'm using the theme is setting
SETI all right so the server restarted
let's just all right cool that's working
but what's not word okay so we were able
to recreate some of this stuff in terms
of the errors so this is no longer
working let's give it a refresh just to
verify that it's not working okay yeah
definitely not working I'm going to make
sure it's not a something weird with the
screen all this is it working now okay
that's interesting it started to work
now
for some reason it did not work I don't
if you guys caught that when we first
loaded the page it did not work we
resize the page and it works which
doesn't really make a whole lot of sense
okay you see here it's not working until
we resize we resize just a little bit
and now it's at least kind of working
it's giving us a weird thing okay
now I'm going to troubleshoot that right
now is I'm in the middle of showing you
this
yeah because some of these a call on the
live chat says it's not working because
your window size is less than 15 40 so I
guess we'll go back and check this out
now yeah so I do have let's go to this
function the scroll effect here so I am
checking for this window size the window
width which should happen is if it's
greater than 15:40 it's just going to
have a different base position but then
it's still going to add us this dis
scroll this position Y which is just
based on the the scroll position so it
should still be working I said but I'm
not going to show - overshoot that now
that's just odd because I did test that
a lot the only different thing that I
was doing was I was testing it on
another screen I don't I don't know why
that is students make such a big
difference but um I guess it does okay
I'm we're getting okay so let me let me
just show you this so for commit message
where we do move remove sticky nav its
own function outside
okay so we move the stickeen out into
its own function outside document dot
ready that's about what we did okay so
if you're not familiar with git it's
version control all I've done is just
I've saved this version of the code and
I may have a little message there just
to say what changed since the last
version
and now I've pushed it on to github
which is a site where you can store your
code and on all your versions so you can
view it other people can view it
collaborate and this repo is available
so since we push this let me switch back
over we're going to go into our server
also looks like I'm still logged in let
me just make a mouse to live in
looks like this says there we go okay so
I wasn't logged in it was still showing
it but it was just kind of lagging a
little bit so let's log back in so I'm
using SSH when you use SSH this is my
local machine right now and I'm just
going to type in my username and then
the IP address I have a private key on
my machine and there's a public key
stored on the server all right those
have to match up and then I can log in
and I don't even need a password so it's
pretty cool I have to log in from this
computer but it prevents people from
trying to you know guess my password or
brute-force attack and get in so now
that I'm in here you can see here's our
folder so let's go in into that folder
this is this has all the same things
that we have on our local machine but
I'm now on the server this is a droplet
on digital ocean I did a few videos on
how to set that up we're going to stop
our server right now as you can see I
just stopped that from running so the
site actually won't work right now and
now I'm going to get pool and all the
changes I've now pulled down from github
so this version and the version on a
local machine that we're just testing
are now exactly the same and now I need
to build this again so I'm going to go
npm run build okay and that's going to
run i'll show you in our package.json
when I say run build that's going to be
equivalent of running next build and
then I'm going to actually start it with
with pn2
and this is what what will be run when I
start I don't think I showed you this
when we set this up but when we set up
the custom server which I think was
yesterday but I did need to change this
to start the
server we give it this environment
variable of production and that
basically the only thing I'm using this
variable for right now is to change the
time out the expiration of the the cache
okay so that's all built doesn't take
very long and now we're going to start
okay
so that started now let's go back to it
and refresh make sure it's working okay
everything's working and now let's give
it a test so we did change some things
so we added that stickiness back in I'm
going to open up dev tools here on the
side and I'll put it right here so that
way we can check and see what kind of
pairs we have let's see mine I don't
want to preserve the log so let's
refresh should we get a clean clean log
here okay so you are getting some stuff
let's see non-passive event listeners
will walk in touchstart event okay we're
getting some stuff I actually have I
have it set to verbose settings so we're
getting a lot of stuff that you might
not normally see all right so our stinky
now is working great let's try this up
alright that's working and if you
remember this actually is just it's it's
just being initialized from our our
document ready function okay so this did
work we're not using that client-side
routing which will actually test out
first I want to go over homepage and see
what's going on there
see sticky networks see all right looks
like that's that's off that's not
working it did stop at some point but
it's stopping a lot farther down that we
wanted to what would give it kind of a
more normal screen size okay I I wasn't
sure what was going on with these images
but it looks like they're working
let's give it a refresh just to
double-check that
okay the images are working it's
possible I think I'm using a source set
to do different image sizes and I may
have now should be working to test that
later okay so this this looks a bit more
like it should and now I want to test
this out to see if we actually are
linking and it looks like that it did
work okay
there we go finally this is what I
expect okay this is what I've been
trying to get to happen almost the
entire time let me tell you what
happened just in case you missed it so
we added a few minutes ago we added this
client-side routing so before we just
had regular link tags it was actually
going back to the server we're getting
page refreshes we had a client-side
routing what happens though with with
client-side routing is you the
document.ready function doesn't fire
again so this never initialized so you
can see this is not working if i refresh
the page it should work so let's do that
let's refresh see it is working so we'll
test this one more time just to just to
test that our theory and demonstrate how
this works we go to the about page I
want to go somewhere that will give me a
message to okay oh I see what's
happening since I'm using source set on
a smaller screen is kind trying to grab
a different image a different sized
image but I forgot to put the correct
route I just went right to the image
folder instead of static so that's why
just a little little typo a little
mistake there
all right so now we're gonna go to
events okay now what you see I think we
did have a little flash here but we
didn't actually have a refresh so these
same errors that we just had on the
homepage have not gone away if we had a
page refresh this should have gone away
so I see I just clicked on news it had a
page refresh all that went away all
right so those should have gone away so
the rep the client-side routing is
working and that also explains why this
isn't working because we're only calling
this from the document.ready function
does that make sense
want to stop and check on you you all
for a second since I've been ignoring
the live stream to try to get this to
work I know there's going to be a little
delay so I'm going to wait basically the
question is does any of this make sense
at all can you see why it's not working
and I'll take just another minute here I
know I'm over my half an hour but I'll
take another minute to fix this we'll
push it to the server and test it again
to show that how to how to make your
jQuery work with the client-side routing
in react so I'll get ready to do the fix
while I'm waiting to hear back from here
okay finally okay so Patrick said it
makes complete sense okay we'll move on
here I know there's there's 43 other
people viewing right now oh okay Daniel
says it works too
awesome so at least two of 43 say that
it works if if you're one of those other
41 people and you are really confused
leave a message in the comments direct
message me on Twitter
re watch the video I'm happy to help
help you try to understand this
especially if you really need to
understand this for a project you're
working on I'd be I'd be more than happy
to talk to you go over this a little bit
more or if you have a much easier or
better way of doing this and you're just
watching this thinking like what is this
idiot doing
please let me know so basically what
we're going to do we have all this this
is our scrolling stuff down here I
haven't put it in its own component yet
eventually I will put it in its own
component because we do have some things
that need to repeat for now we don't we
don't have a ton of events so this might
be one of the things that just gets hard
coded um then this is weird sorry I just
got distracted by this little oh okay my
syntax highlighting just made it look
weird but this is corrected we want
event slash title it's highlighting some
of the stuff as if it were JavaScript
when it's really in here I am for some
reason my plugin that's supposed to
highlight react stuff more accurately as
stuff working I think I probably just
need to restart my editor all right so
here's what we're going to do let's grab
this from sticking up because why type
when you can copy and paste and handle
throw this in here and I believe we call
this H scroll or yep H scroller so we're
going to call this on component in mount
there's only one thing I'm worried about
I'm where
that this will actually fire before this
stuff loads down here if this was its
own component I would be less worried
about it because it would only be so
we'll see if it works if it doesn't work
that's probably why and III do have one
more thing that could be done to fix it
if that happens okay so we save that
let's go over here let's go back to okay
so we've changed this we're going to do
a git commit and I'm combining to get
add and the commit message into one and
we're going to call H stroller from the
component we're calling a stroller from
component did mount okay we're going to
push that now let's go back to our
server and let's first we'll stop it now
let's get pool now let's build if you
notice I'm using NPM on the server but
on my local machine I'm using yarn yarn
is faster I like yarn more but it just
simplifies things on the server if I
restaurant straight NPM at least for now
I have run yarn on the server too it's
not a big deal but it's just one less
thing I have to load on the server there
was some a couple months ago when I set
something similiar up there was some
weird bug where I I couldn't run yarn
with p.m. - I had to use NPM it was
something with
it was it was looking for us so I I
looked up the problem that I couldn't
get it fixed so I just stuck with
running NPM it's possible that it has
changed now there's been up updates for
p.m. to and you are in since that time
but just in case you're wondering that's
why it's different now let's just start
it up again to the build is complete all
right now we're back online and let's
refresh if you remember we need to
actually navigate away and back to there
are sticky networks this should work
alright that still works now let's go
let's go out to the home page just to
see if this if this works as well which
it should be working right okay that
works awesome sticky now is working on
the home page and we're not getting any
crazy areas except this one that we knew
about already and that's just my fault
for not citing the right path now let's
go back to the vents now what should
happen you can see we didn't actually
have a page refresh because we still
have all the same stuff in our console
now what should happen here is as I
scroll down this should work and it does
ok so just to recap I'm gonna I'm going
to finish up here before it ends I am
going to show another video interview I
did from syntax spawn and it's only like
a 30 second video and I'll go through
the live chat and answer any questions
so just to recap in case people are
joining in late did Seattle normally
when you use jQuery you're going to put
things inside your document your
document ready function okay and then
that way if you have to look up elements
on the page they're loaded so they will
be there the problem is when you're
using react and you're using client-side
routing which is common with react and
you you go from one page to another and
you don't actually have a page refresh
the document
dot ready function doesn't fire again so
your code won't work the first time it
ran it won't be able to it wouldn't have
found that element on the page because
you're on a different page so then when
you switch that that code will just
never run the solution or at least one
solution is pull out that code to yours
you're still in your main app J S or
whatever you want to call it scripts
dodged as you're still in there you
still can use jQuery as normal but
you've just pulled out literally you
just copy and paste that code that's
doing the thing that whatever you want
it to do that jQuery and you just throw
it a function name it whatever you want
and then you go into your your component
and then the component did mount
function which this
this isn't next specific this is in and
react so any type of react thing that
you're doing will have this well I
haven't worked with react native so I'm
assuming req negative has something like
this or maybe the same thing but
basically you're going to have component
did now and you're good call it from in
there and that's going to make sure that
when you do your routing like we just
did okay so when I go to a different
page here you can see I haven't done
that with the side nav yet so it still
doesn't work so we're going to a
different page and now we're going to go
back to events events right now is the
only page where we've enabled the
client-side routing for we've gone back
to events the document ready function is
not fired but since this component is
now on the page and it wasn't this
component has now mounted and in this
case this the entire page is one
component if this will be split out at
some point but since that's the first
time this component is loading its
mounted it actually calls that that
function okay so hopefully I know a
couple you said that that did
make sense so hope I didn't confuse you
too much it seems like nobody said
they're confused yet so I hope that was
helpful for you I'm going to repeat what
I said at the beginning ideally you
don't want to use jQuery when you're
using react okay there are some weird
side effects that happen because react
is trying to track everything in the DOM
and if you change it with jQuery instead
of the reactor way to do it then it can
mess up reacts tracking of the dawn okay
and you will get some errors and stuff
it won't always break your site okay
obviously we're using it here our sites
not breaking we're not you know the
world is not ending by using jQuery and
react together but I expect that a lot
of you might be in a situation where
you're converting a site to react or for
whatever reason it's going to be a big
deal to try to do things in vanilla
JavaScript or the react way to do it
when you can do it very easily with
jQuery sometimes it's just a time issue
like with me right now I just really
don't have time to figure out how to do
all these things in vanilla JavaScript I
know it's all possible but it's just
faster use jQuery right now so hopefully
that helps some of you I'm gonna play
let me play this video for you and then
after the video I'll do a quick run
through the live chat see if there's any
questions that I can answer for you
right now
and then I'll have to go because this
site needs to launch on Thursday and
there's a lot of work to do so I'll
pretty much be taking breaks for
sleeping and that's about it until we
launch so let me I did this yesterday
and it worked
so I'm gonna try this again I know you
can't see this but I'm literally just
unplugging my headphones so that I can
play the audio from this video on my on
my speakers on the Mac lemme there we go
I have an iMac so I'm just going to put
these through the speakers
and the microphone on the iMac will pick
it up I don't have any special equipment
at this point so hopefully this will
work and it's loud enough me full screen
it for you okay so this is just a very
short interview from syntax Cohen it's a
conference that went to last week really
great conference and this is a Ron I I
know I'm going to mess up his last name
sorry Ron um so Ron AK right ratha rai
tha tha so sorry Ryan he's a really nice
guy I got to talk to him and go to Lee
he did a talk on AWS lambda so let's
hear what advice he had he's going to
say what his name is where he works what
he does and he'll give some it what he's
excited about with new technology and
some advice for new new coders all right
say yes I'm wrong I work at boomtown as
the back and suffered over the chassis
approached me he asked me about you know
and to talk about your poker game and
talk to people right ah see uh one of
the questions was what was the
technology I'm excited about one of them
is serverless
the surrealist framework that just came
out and it works at live that a bunch of
other cloud platforms it's pretty cool
pretty nifty work live and advice that I
have for people trying to get into
coding is that sure it's nice to watch
courses and you do projects but try
stepping out of your comfort zone that
will help you immensely alright so
that's it for the interview really short
interview some of the other ones were
were longer but I think I have maybe
three more to show you let me go to the
live chat quickly before we before we
end okay I did answer some somebody
asked how to get started with react and
I answered that earlier so if you're
interested in hearing that answer watch
the re recording this video and go back
to the beginning
Ezra is
as I'm still a beginner so I'm already
lost sorry about that react was like
super confusing to me when I started to
use it so just just stick with it it it
will click at some point all right
somebody's asking about my text editor
so it is Adam and I'm using the SETI
theme okay not a lot of questions
somebody else says they're beginner and
they're lost so I apologize if I lost
you I its if you're not familiar with
reacts or even familiar that much with
JavaScript I I could see you you would
definitely be lost so I'm not always
going to be at this kind of level doing
videos I expect when I'm done with this
project then I'll go back and probably
start up a new project or get back to
just some things that are like basic
HTML CSS things so since this is just my
day to day job it's just a big mix of
things so if this was a little bit over
your head then you know thun thun back
in what some of the older videos and you
know just follow me on Twitter I'll
tweet out what the topic is every day
and you can see if it's a topic that
interests you that seems like it's more
at your level than then tune in there's
definitely some really like beginner
type stuff that that has been on this
show and will be on this show especially
like as we get started in projects so
hopefully there'll be something for
everyone at every at every skill level
my hope is that some people will get a
lot from this some people if they're
beginners and some people who are more
advanced will give me some advice and
and you know we can kind of work
together to learn from each other okay
we had one more question here how how do
we manage this sticky nav UI check out
the playlist so live coding with jesse
is a playlist on the free code camp
channel in that playlist you'll see
maybe
two weeks ago I did a video where we
live coded that sticking up and I went
through that so check out that video if
anything is confusing just leave a
comment on the video and I'll get back
to you and try to explain it more but we
did I'm pretty sure that I went over
that part in in a video and if I'm just
totally losing my mind and I didn't make
a video leave a comment as well and then
maybe I'll put that on the list for for
a video to make later on you can also
check out all the code for that on
github the link is in the description so
there's any other questions get them in
in the next five seconds otherwise I'll
see I'll be back on tomorrow same time
I'll probably be more stressed tomorrow
than normal because at that point it
will be less than 24 hours to launch and
I will have probably been working quite
a lot between then and now
so hopefully this site is looking way
more finished tomorrow and maybe our
livestream the launch so we'll see I
haven't set an exact time for that
launch but that might be cool to
actually live stream the you know
pointing the domain name to the right
servers trying it out and maybe we'll
probably be doing some testing tomorrow
so maybe I'll show you how I test with
browserstack and and things like that
we'll try to find some bugs right that's
it for today thanks for watching and
I'll be back tomorrow